in aztec mythology the legend of the
five sons is the creation myth of our
world
the dawning of the fifth son brought
about the era in which humans were
created and is the era in which we
currently live
according to the myth this sun was
created by the gods but was not able to
move across the sky
that is not without the nourishment of
sacrifice
the gods themselves were the first to be
sacrificed to the sun setting the
tradition of human sacrifice that the
aztecs would later follow
the god shalottal however did not want
to be sacrificed to evade detection he
changed himself into other forms
first the maize plant then the agave
plant and finally the water monster the
axolotl when he was found his brother
ketzel koat spared his life but banished
him to live forever in darkness as an
axolotl
today this water monster is believed to
still hold the spirit of a god
axolotls are a type of salamander found
only in the area of lake sochi milko
outside mexico city near the ancient
capital of the aztecs tenochtitlan
and beyond their spiritual ties axolotls
are unlike any other salamander they
live permanently in the water and in
fact live permanently in their juvenile
form
never maturing into their adult body a
forever tadpole and on top of its
age-defying ability the axolotl can
regenerate almost any part of its body
from missing limbs tails organs parts of
the eye and even parts of its brain
for hundreds of years the axolotl has
been central to our understanding of how
our own organs develop and function its
unique physiology holding the answers to
many of our most pressing biological
questions
and now we hope to crack the code of its
regenerating superpowers to one day be
able to harness them for ourselves but
with only a few hundred kilometers of
waterways that remain of its natural
habitat the axolotl is on the brink of
total annihilation in the wild and the
time to unlock these mysteries is
running out
why is the axolotl so different from
every other vertebrate what is it
exactly about their very unusual
physiology that makes them the most
important amphibian known to science
[Music]
axolotls are members of the tiger
salamander species complex and they
evolved relatively recently compared to
other salamander species in the region
they grow to be about 23 centimeters
long and come in a variety of colors and
unlike almost all other salamanders they
are neotenic meaning that they keep
juvenile characteristics into adulthood
they never undergo metamorphosis for
them this means they remain aquatic
never venturing onto land
they keep their external feathery gills
and tail fins and they lack movable
eyelids
when they were first shipped from mexico
to prominent french zoologist augusta
dumaril in the 1860s he was certain that
the axolotls were the larvae of an
unknown type of salamander
that is until six months later when his
specimens very unexpectedly reproduced
and because the adult stage of animals
is defined by sexual maturity these
reproducing axolotls had to be adults
just how strange the axolotl is was only
beginning to be revealed
overall retaining juvenile traits seems
like a cute but weird thing to happen in
nature
at first glance it looks like a whole
species that's had its growth
permanently stunted but although
axolotls are one of the only salamanders
to stay in their juvenile form
other salamanders from the region can
sometimes be found doing the same thing
with some individuals staying in the
water for their whole lives
at first naturalists didn't know what to
make of this phenomenon but looking at
where these salamanders lived started to
give a clue as to why this may be
selected for in nature
all of the mexican lakes where they are
found have a few key things in common
first they are all large relatively
permanent bodies of water at least they
used to be before human intervention
second the lakes are surrounded by
desert and in many cases are the only
permanent body of water in the region
and third all of these lakes
historically did not have any large
predatory fish
the salamanders in these lakes sometimes
or always fail to mature into adulthood
because these lakes are the only
suitable habitat in the midst of a harsh
and dry terrestrial environment
salamanders normally metamorphose to
take advantage of both water and land
but only if the land is somewhat damp
but staying in the water forever is a
strategy that only works with no major
predators lurking beneath the surface
along with certain ph temperature and
altitude requirements
these mexican lakes just happen to
completely fit the bill giving the
salamanders a unique ability to thrive
there
for a while it was thought that the
axolotl always fails to undergo
metamorphosis that its neoteny is a
permanent feature of its biology
while this may be true most of the time
it isn't true all of the time as french
zoologist dumarill learned in 1865 when
he was given an even bigger surprise
from his axolotl specimens
to his shock some of the individuals in
his care transformed into their adult
land-living form
they looked sort of like tiger
salamanders but different enough to
still be considered their own unique
species
dumaril searched the rest of his life
for an explanation of why these axolotls
transformed but died before he ever got
the answer
but in the early 1900s the
transformation of the axolotl again came
to the front of research interests
during this time researchers were
narrowing in on thyroid gland tissue as
a mechanism for amphibian metamorphosis
and the axolotl was the most suited
animal to clearly demonstrate its effect
when axolotls were fed thyroid tissue
from livestock the axolotls would
metamorphose losing their external gills
shedding their larval skin and venturing
onto land
basically thyroid tissue is a real-life
moonstone for the axolotl
in other instances axolotls can
transform when forced to breathe air but
this is stressful on the animal and
takes much longer
however it may be why some in captivity
have unexpectedly metamorphosed
the discovery of transforming axolotls
played a central role in the road to our
understanding of thyroid hormones like
thyroxine which was first isolated in
1915 and synthesized in 1926.
this marked the beginning of what would
become the axolotl's immense
contribution to medical research
all organisms have some level of
regenerative abilities
for some animals regeneration is just a
part of life
flatworms and hydras can regenerate
their whole bodies even from a tiny
piece of their original selves
starfish octopuses or even crabs can
lose an arm and grow it back without
much of a problem
but these animals all share something in
common they're all invertebrates
in vertebrates like us regeneration is
pretty much limited to regrowing skin or
scar tissue over a wound except for our
liver we can't regrow our organs nor our
limbs
in fact almost no vertebrate can
regenerate much beyond what we can
that is except for the axolotl and the
other members of the salamander order
the only other vertebrates that can
regrow limbs are frogs but frogs lose
the ability once they fully turn into
their adult form the axolotl retains its
regeneration ability throughout its
entire life
the way an axolotl regrows a limb begins
with the limbs surviving cells
once the limb has been severed or lost a
blood clot rapidly stops the bleeding at
the cut and a layer of cells covers the
area of amputation this part is not so
different from the way we would heal
then over the next few days the cells
underneath the epidermis begin to
rapidly divide forming a cone-shaped
structure known as a blastoma also
called the regeneration bud
the blastoma is what holds the key to
regeneration it's where regular bone
cartilage or muscle cells
de-differentiate meaning they lose their
identity and transform back into stem
cells
slowly they start reforming bone skin
and veins much like stem cells would do
when the animal is first developing in
its egg
as the cells in the blastoma continue to
divide nerves and blood vessels connect
it to the rest of the body the limb
eventually grows back completely looking
like an exact copy of the limb that was
lost
and while total limb regeneration is
impressive enough axolotls are also
capable of something that seems like it
should be downright impossible
regrowing parts of their brain
in mammals like us and in fact most
vertebrates neurons typically only grow
in the embryonic stage
any neurogenesis that happens in
adulthood is quite limited if the brain
is damaged in adulthood it usually can't
regenerate new neurons blood vessels or
tissue
yet somehow doing this is no problem for
the axolotl by de-differentiating stem
cells they can add new neurons
throughout their life and can regenerate
the spinal cord and parts of the brain
after an injury
salamanders are the only four-legged
vertebrates that can transform regular
cells back into stem cells allowing them
to redevelop into new tissue
this may seem like a superpower but the
axolotl doesn't actually have special
regeneration genes to do this they are
simply regulating their genes
differently from other animals
this fact gives scientists hope that we
may have this ability still locked
within us
an ability that if unlocked could
greatly benefit people suffering from
certain organ failures amputation of a
limb or serious burns
while we still don't know the exact
mechanisms that allow the axolotl to
de-differentiate cells
some of the key components are starting
to be unveiled many of them resembling
the cells and molecules that are already
at work in our bodies
one way to learn what molecules and
cells are necessary for an axolotl to
regenerate is to look for molecular
tweaks that cause them to lose their
regenerative ability for example
macrophages are known to be critical
during inflammation in response to an
injury in many animals and have
previously been connected to
regeneration and so researchers found
that injecting a drug that eliminates
the macrophages in an axolotl's limb
before amputation causes it to form scar
tissue instead of regenerate
this shows that macrophages a type of
cell we readily have are an important
component for regeneration
researchers similarly found that a
protein called transforming growth
factor beta is key in axolotl
regeneration a molecule that is also
essential in preventing scar tissue in
injured human embryos during the first
trimester
and on top of this researchers have also
found that both mice and humans can
regenerate a partially amputated finger
or toe though humans lose this ability
as they get older researchers believe
that this is due to a type of stem cell
that lies beneath the fingernail that
normally helps the fingernails to
perpetually grow
they now think that these cells could
also be a remnant from a time when our
regeneration abilities were stronger
the regrowth of the mice digits studied
depends on two certain types of proteins
called wnt and fgf2 proteins and certain
signaling pathways
proteins and pathways that all seem to
be the same as those in salamanders
during regeneration
all of this suggests that we may
partially retain the same regeneration
abilities as the axolotl abilities that
could one day be reawakened for this
reason the axolotl is one of the most
incredible and most important research
animals in science
along with becoming a beloved pet in
freshwater aquariums worldwide and yet
they are facing almost complete
annihilation in the wild the
conservation story of the axolotl is a
unique one and if we're not careful we
risk losing one of the most incredible
creatures on earth
the wild axolotl is teetering on the
brink of extinction
their population has exponentially
declined in the last few decades in a
1998 survey it was reported that around
6 000 individuals lived per square
kilometer in their habitat in 2015 just
35 individuals were found per square
kilometer
they were predicted to go extinct in the
wild in 2020 though they have just
barely escaped this fate
no one knows exactly how many are left
now but the numbers are dire today the
axolotl is found naturally in only one
place
like sochi milko
but the modern diversion of this lake is
more like a series of small canals it's
a phantom of what it used to be
representing only two percent of the
original massive wetland system
centuries ago this area contained
several great lakes which were home to
many mesoamerican cultures including the
teotihuacanos the toltecs and later the
aztecs
at the time of the spanish conquest in
1519 the size of these lakes would have
covered much of modern day mexico city
due to its naturally shallow waters and
its freshwater springs in the south lake
sochi milko was the center of chinampa
agriculture in the centuries before the
spanish arrived these artificial islands
created an extensive network of canals
the ancient cities here in a way looked
a lot like the venice of today
here the axolotl thrived alongside
humans
but over time the population of the area
grew and grew and eventually the lakes
were all drained with the exception of
lake sochi milko to prevent flooding and
to allow urban expansion
what remains of lake sochi milko today
is highly polluted full of dangerous
algae blooms and invasive large fish
which both out compete and eat the
axolotls it's no surprise that the
axolotl is almost gone there
and yet in labs around the world the
axolotl is abundant they've even been
called the white mice of amphibians
since they are ideal for research and
are easy to rear in the lab
they are the most distributed amphibian
in the world so you may ask the question
if the axolotl is thriving in aquariums
and labs what's the issue
unfortunately the lab colonies are not
staying healthy
these captive populations are becoming
inbred lacking the genetic diversity
that wards off disease
to help mitigate this scientists have
crossbred the axolotls in captivity with
the similar species the tiger salamander
but this has left many lab specimens
with a host of foreign genes meaning
that they aren't quite the same as wild
axolotls anymore
one proposed solution to the decline of
wild axolotls is to simply reintroduce
some of the captive population back into
their natural habitat
but until the lake is cleaned up putting
them back would be a death sentence
and despite the efforts of some
scientists and conservationists like
sochi milko becoming clean and healthy
anytime soon seems unlikely
instead of reintroducing them into their
original habitat
some scientists have a different idea to
give the axolotls a new home
one suitable site has been identified
near mexico's national autonomous
university a freshwater lake has been
born out of an abandoned quarry and
researchers are now using it as an
ecological research site dozens of
axolotls have been released here and are
tracked using radio transmitters
eventually these research subjects are
expected to breed here and a new type of
semi-wild population may be born
perhaps with the introduction of wild
caught axolotls along with the
lab-reared ones genetic diversity could
improve
and even though it's a different
ecosystem than the swampy canals that
they evolved in places like this may be
the best option for the long-term
survival of these magnificent creatures
mexico is one of the most bio-diverse
countries in the world it sits with
brazil colombia and indonesia at the
very top of the biodiversity list with
thousands of unique endemic species
it's estimated that more than 10
of all of the world's species live in
mexico
for this reason it's considered to be a
mega diverse country the axolotl is far
from the only notable native species
that mexico has to offer the mexican
prairie dog burrowing owls
the mexican wolf the rarest subspecies
of wolf in north america and the
american bison the largest land animal
in the americas are all amazing
creatures that live in the grasslands of
mexico
grasslands an ecosystem that may be easy
to overlook are in fact teeming with
biodiversity
the number of different types of grasses
there is comparable to the number of
different types of trees in a tropical
rainforest
i personally didn't know much about this
incredible ecosystem before watching my
wild backyard on curiosity stream
the janos biosphere reserve episode
grabbed my attention especially since i
live in texas and this ecosystem is
truly in my backyard
other episodes explore the unexpected
wildlife of new york city or the
stunning national parks of argentina
it follows local ecologists and
scientists as they show us the hidden
wonders of wildlife that exist all
around us
curiosity stream is a streaming platform
with thousands of high quality
documentaries like this one
and now curiositystream is partnered
with us to offer an incredible deal by
signing up to curiositystream you now
also get a subscription to nebula nebula
is a streaming platform made by me and
several other educational youtube
content creators
it's a place where we can upload our
videos ad free and a place where we can
experiment with new original content
by signing up to the bundle deal you'll
get access to both curiosity stream and
nebula where you can access content like
the hour-long director's cut of our
partner channel real engineering's
latest 787 video with more detailed
explanations and with no ads
full documentaries like this one would
be hard for us to put on youtube its
length not favored by the algorithm gods
but on nebula there are no restrictions
no algorithms or no demonetization just
creators uploading the content that they
want to make
signing up to the bundle deal is also
the best way to support this channel so
by signing up at curiositystream.com
real science you'll get a subscription
to curiosity stream and a subscription
to nebula for just 14.79 for the entire
year and if you're looking for something
else to watch right now you can watch
our previous video about bee colony
democracy or watch real engineering's
latest video the insane engineering of
the gen x engine
[Music]